un grifo a cuentagotas el gigante ruso
de energía gazprom redujo el suministro
de gas a alemania a través del gasoducto
nord stream 1 dejándolo a solo el 20 por
ciento de su capacidad según moscú el
corte se debe a problemas de
mantenimiento en las enormes turbinas
que presuriza en el gas pero los líderes
europeos aseguran que se trata de una
estrategia rusa para convertir los
suministros en un arma de guerra con el
fin de desestabilizar los mercados
energéticos del continente
y siquiera tienen las agallas para decir
estamos en una confrontación económica
bélica con ustedes bien nos han contado
una y otra vez está ya sabes la
rocambolesca historia sobre las turbinas
que simplemente no es cierta
nord stream 1 transporta gas desde el
puerto ruso de víborg bajo el mar
báltico hasta grave falta en alemania
las sanciones occidentales por la guerra
en ucrania han detenido la apertura de
su gasoducto hermano north stream 2 en
junio rusia redujo el flujo del nord
stream 1 al 60 por ciento de su
capacidad alegando que las sanciones
impedían el regreso de una turbina
enviada a canadá para su reparación tras
un breve corte total el suministro a
través del producto volvió a hacer del
40 por ciento antes del último anuncio
de nuevos cortes alemania afirma que las
turbinas en cuestión no están sujetas a
las sanciones de la unión europea así
que cualquier retraso en la devolución
de las piezas reparadas se debe a la
falta de documentos aduaneros rusos el
último corte de suministro se produce
cuando los países europeos se apresuran
a abastecerse de gas por temor a un
posible corte total por parte de moscú
en invierno cuando la demanda de
calefacción es máxima